a year
of working from home the pandemic has
actually reset the way we work entirely
we want our staff to have the best of
both worlds the flexibility of working
from home and the power working together
at the office
that actually yields ideas and
friendships
through this exhibition we hope to
empower the individual
and their teams with knowledge and
understanding
to chart their new ways of working as
unique as it may be
[Music]
our inspiration is to actually capture
the emotion of
the disruption of work during the period
of a year and we are all
away from office workplace
[Music]
we wanted to create this immersive and
participatory and
fun experience to help them recall their
feelings of
working with their teammates during
lockdown and during working from home
how do you feel about collaborating and
working together
through the stages of not being able to
see somebody to be able
to then communicate more effectively
based on things
we all went through a very unusual
experience and
had certain findings about our lifestyle
and the way we work
so by creating this exhibition we wanted
to share our findings
with ergonomics everybody needs it but
everybody is a different
height everybody has a different weight
so how do you find that perfect
element and perfect sizing fitting the
task to the user
our customers are asking for a hybrid
workspace so the inspiration for this
space comes from that it
shows how customers can work from home
and also how they can collaborate more
in the office the inspiration that we
have for this booth is about human
centric lighting
with acoustic comfort by adjusting the
color temperature
of the lighting you're really affecting
your more
from working in the cubicle you have
that kind of privacy
but now the workspace has been changing
to open plan
and also collaboration co-working space
so our solution
is our privacy port they can talk
privately without having to
disturb the others
[Music]
it's not about past precedence but
embracing
different points of view to create
something meaningful
an ongoing journey or change is
inevitable
let's embrace it and perhaps lead it
[Music]
you